when nvidia first announced its rtx 3090
founders edition video card and the
subsequent partner models for this time
it was pretty clear actually in the
marketing slides that this would be a
titan replacement the titan video cards
have never been really meant for gaming
workloads but that hasn't stopped nvidia
in the past from marketing them as such
the titan rtx for example made claims
about being the fastest gaming gpu ever
but it was never really emphasized that
hard especially not in media typically
with these titan class cards really what
you're looking for is workstation style
performance but this time there's been
heavy emphasis on gaming for the 30 90
and specifically 8k gaming for a 1500
video card
uh for which the
selection of 8k displays is probably
lower in overall quantity than the
quantity of 3090s that will ever exist
so today we're reviewing the rtx 3090
and we are asking the primary question
of why
namely why nvidia
why did you do it before that this video
is brought to you by us and the gn store
for our 1 million subscribers limited
edition foil t-shirt the front has the
gn logo and a gold play button like the
ones youtube sends out and the back has
our history on youtube dating back over
a decade the shirt is custom made with a
high quality 100 cotton and features a
shiny gold foil one million crept up on
us way faster than expected so these
shirts are still in production but you
can guarantee you'll get one by
backordering on
store.gamersnexus.net our previous
limited shirts have sold out in just
three to four weeks each time and like
those previous shirts we'll be using the
funding from our one million subs
special shirt to purchase new testing
equipment for our reviews back order the
limited 1 million subscriber on
store.gamersnexus.net
so as a workstation card the 3090 does
gen this is very heavy does genuinely
have a a lot of potential upside and
that's something that we have been
looking into
andrew for example on our team works in
blender and
game engines regularly and that's a use
case that makes a lot of sense for the
3090 and the reasoning is that when
you're working with especially early on
in the art pipeline with assets that are
not yet optimized not yet compressed or
finalized you really just want something
that can run the viewport relatively
smoothly relatively high fps
while you're sorting everything out the
optimization can be done later so
it's often the developer side that would
benefit from a card like this there are
also things like quadros in existence
and at that point you're looking at
things like certified drivers as well if
you're for example boeing where you need
some kind of certification almost like
you want a nist traceable certificate
for certain testing utilities to back
you up legally but this is a different
deployment so in a game engine or a game
development environment it makes sense
to have a better computer than the
average player would be on because you
do need to just build the thing first
and worry about optimizing it later
surely this is not news to anybody if
you look at the level of optimization in
the number of games over the past few
years the rtx 3090 might cost 114 more
than the rtx 3080 but don't worry this
is a workstation card not a gaming
not a
we're being told it's a gaming card so
we're going to be looking at the gaming
performance today
of the rtx 3090. apparently millions of
people have now been told that this is
in fact a gaming video card and they've
been told that the 8k gaming experience
is nothing short of excellent at least
for the titles thus far shown and
controlled by nvidia so now that we've
received the message that this card is
actually meant for gaming and it's not
just a boring workstation pro viz card
it makes sense to test it for 8k gaming
without
the mantle of nvidia's marketing
requirements sitting on top of the chart
uh so it's probably time to look at that
we'll look through that today as an
aside there are a lot of games that
don't even run 8k properly some of the
ones we tested for example were running
at 6651 by 3741 natively separately two
we should note that 8k
8k in giant air quotes there is
in and of itself a [__] moniker this
is because 8k is 7640 by 4320 pixels and
that's about 33 million pixels if you
multiply the two numbers so if you look
at that against so-called 4k which is at
this point a universally accepted
shorthand for another technically
inaccurate
uh naming convention that's 8.3 million
pixels 8k is not two 4k displays you
would need to run quad sli displays at
4k in order to get quote-unquote 8k
so that stated that's obviously a hell
of a lot more pixels to cram through the
gpu pipeline and anyone expecting fully
representative
depictions out of doom eternal which
could run fluidly on a tamagotchi
is going to be sorely disappointed and
obviously that was hyperbole
but it's not far off so nvidia started
its marketing with a simple throwaway
reference of 8k gaming and it did
technically have the caveat on the slide
of being rt enabled and dlss enabled
which means it's not actually
8k it's just sort of kind of 8k
but that ran away from nvidia once the
marketing team or whomever was in charge
of it started pushing media down the
pipes one day before launch of actual
third-party reviews
with a dictation over the type of
discussion that would happen in the
content and that is something for which
we don't necessarily fault the content
creators but rather nvidia's own teams
which has decided that now that it has
been given a pistol it will repeatedly
shoot itself in both feet not just one
so following up what could have been an
easy slam dunk of a launch with the
impressive performance gains of the 3080
a card which we could actually recommend
at the end of the review process unlike
a lot of the 20 series cards
it it ran out of stock and then it
followed it up with this continual push
on the 8k aspect of a card which has 24
gigabytes of memory which is really
meant for the artist someone who needs
or maybe a cad user an engineer someone
who actually needs the memory to have a
high enough speed viewport or a highly
responsive
work application
it's being shown as
8k beneficial so uh here's the chart for
8k gaming it's
well
it's a console experience that's the
best spin that we have for it gta 5 a
game from 2015 from 2013 gets 32 fps
average the lows are not great and call
attention to the need for a frame time
plot at least with other games which
we'll get to shortly but that's okay
we'll look at something else shadow of
the tomb raider does a
really
poor really fluid console like
experience
at
at 30.4
at 30.4 fps average that 0.4
that makes it better than consoles
really a lot better than consoles those
suck
and with shadow of the tomb raider which
has that fluid console like experience
you might think that 11 fps for the lows
is bad
but actually
moving on strange brigade a game that
many people play and some enjoy ran at
50 fps average this was the best score
that we plotted in a game that actually
rendered that so-called eight so called
k because dlss doesn't count as actually
8k and this isn't running it it's also
one of the best optimized games out
there so this is not common nor is it
fair to say that it can be extrapolated
market wide to even hit this 50 number
horizon zero dawn as an example of this
had us at 32 fps average with lows at 24
and 16. red dead 2 on only high settings
put us at 34 fps average with lows as
far down as 15.7 0.1 percent hitman 2
which is old had us at 37 fps average
which is more dumpster tier performance
here's a frame time plot from shadow of
the tomb raider as a reminder lower is
better but more consistent his best it's
sometimes difficult to weigh low frame
times versus consistent frame time
excursions of 4 to 8 milliseconds
fortunately this chart makes it easy to
call this an objectively bad experience
we're running between 4 milliseconds and
90 frame to frame so just about every
single frame produced in this game feels
like the google stadia launch this is
one of the worst frame time plots we've
ever set eyes upon so our
congratulations to nvidia for making 8k
truly possible there are more numbers
that we included too and ran but they're
technically not valid because the games
didn't actually support 8k and when we
checked in later by taking simple
screenshots we realized that they were
running below 8k for example at 66.51 by
37.41 so even if you like 30 fps average
you shouldn't expect all games to be 8k
gaming ready and that's not to mention
the cost of actual displays or
availability of them where you have one
primary
desktop like computer display available
and then you've got the marketed ones
that were shown in media online
previously where you're talking thirty
thousand sixty thousand dollars per
display and it's all very unfortunate
that nvidia decided to nuke its launch
with this 8k marketing because otherwise
if it had stayed free and clear of it
our review basically would have been
here's a couple of production benchmarks
here's some gaming benchmarks but by the
way the gaming stuff doesn't matter that
much it's not marketed to those people
it's a workstation card and we'll
revisit with more workstation stuff
later and here's a whole bunch of
thermals and acoustics too instead
what's happened is
here's this [__] marketing claim
that nvidia has driven into the ground
to the effect that it has now moved away
via a game of telephone from all of the
original caveats that nvidia had on its
slides during jensen juan's presentation
and is now just 8k gaming is possible
not 8k gaming asterisk is possible but
just that 8k is finally here and that's
where the message got lost in the game
of telephone so ultimately this should
be a workstation card
but we've got a lot more stuff to do and
the benchmarks will still be helpful for
those of you who are trying to buy one
of these especially for a workstation
application even though we're not
looking at those numbers today because
we were busy validating the 8k claims by
the way
invalid
doom doesn't count and neither does dlss
in certain titles it's got to be more
than that so
we're looking at thermals contacts
quality we'll have a separate teardown
video check back for the teardown video
of course later in the day and then we
are also planning to do a whole bunch of
overclocking with this in live streams
which will hopefully go up on day of
launch or maybe the day after there are
places for the card uh unfortunately it
was mis-marketed but we can still help
out with the thermals the acoustics the
gaming performance if you actually care
about that outside of 8k and then
workstation will have to come later with
viewport validation and performance
power testing is next we're putting this
forward in the review because it's
becoming interesting with these cards
mostly because of how high it is the rtx
3090 is driving towards big impact on
power supply selection as we've been
doing for over a year now we're testing
out the pcie slot and pcie cables not at
the wall with a custom interposer that
gamersnexus built but we've also added
pcat recently for more test
accessibility in the process furmark is
first here's the chart this is a power
virus workload to fully load the cards
the rtx 39d fe stock card draws 356
watts alone not total system draw but
card drop and that has it 10 percent
higher in power consumption than the
3080 for some of the most impressively
inefficient performance gains since
amd's rx 590. nvidia talks huge game in
its press day marketing where it claims
that you can overclock the cards and
throw increasingly high power at them
and they'll continue to scale well this
hasn't proven correct in even one remote
aspect of performance increases thus far
just overclocking the 3080 as we showed
in our live streams gets you about three
percent in gains without liquid nitrogen
and only 15 that but this card shows
even worse scaling than that thus far
the cards aren't as power hungry as
leaks may have suggested but the
efficiency for frame rate gains hits
diminishing returns and did so long ago
this is not the scaling we were led to
expect for something that is being
marketed as a gaming card despite being
probably more adequately marketed as a
production or workstation cart
overclocking runs 408 watts or 15
increase whereas the 3080 oc ran 373
watts a 50 watt increase against stock
for its two and a half to three percent
gains if you're wondering about gaming
power consumption it's not much
different since we're ultimately bound
by power targets in the ev bios total
war three kingdoms at 4k ultra which is
our most intensive gaming workload we
test runs the 3090 stock card at 352
watts to 358 watts depending on
resolution and even still it's 409 watts
with an overclock at 4k the 3080 fe
required 314 to 321 watts for the same
test when stock if you're a professional
and can use the 3090 for those
applications the power is potentially
worth it you might not care for
efficiency and you'll need to budget for
additional cooling and if building a
smaller render box with multiple of
these you'll seriously need to consider
room temperature during renders server
farms don't need to worry about this but
they're also technically not allowed to
use geforce cards but for a render farm
maybe in your house or small business
you will need to think about the
accessibility of ac to a room with
multiple these in one machine our next
test was for pressure of the cold plate
as it contacts the die this was done
after all other testing as it required
disassembly of the cooler the tear down
process will be in a video going up
later today the pseudo color pressure
map shows the points of highest contact
and pressure similar to the 3080 fe
cooler we see a triangulated pattern of
three key holes in the coverage which
are filled with thermal paste at full
assembly and then we also see some
additional holes in coverage that were
not present on the 3080 fe overall we'd
rate this contact as acceptable but it
could still be a lot flatter we'll show
the comparison chart in our cold plate
flatness test for
a better idea of what's going on here's
the cold plate flatness chart measured
in microns of depth from a known zero
point the rtx 3090 cooler is overall
more consistent in measurement than the
rtx 3080 fe cooler but has a much
greater peak and a wider range from the
best to the worst measurement by
comparison the 30 90 fe cooler is
overall flatter than our 3080 fe cooler
with a few exceptions in those peaks but
still not quite as good as a strix
cooler or other heat pipe and cold plate
solution here's a look at the thermal
frequency response of the rtx 3090 fe
for this chart we're running fully auto
controlled to determine the v bios
temperature target and the frequency
that's sustained at said target the
frequency ends up peaking at about 2 000
megahertz at the start then falls to
around 1890 to 1905 megahertz once the
temperature rises to target the target
in this v bios appears to be about 68
degrees celsius as a reminder the
temperature of the card is controlled
almost more by v-bios than even the
cooler itself because the cooler simply
follows the v-bios target to get true
comparisons between coolers you need to
noise normalize and ideally power
normalize for perspective the 3080 fe
was maintained in about 1920 to 1935
megahertz when fully auto controlled so
as is usual the lower skew card is
running a bit higher frequency due to
the cut down die here's the thermal rpm
response showing how the automatic fan
curve responds to temperature rise in
this one the rtx 390 fe temperature
quickly settled at around 68 degrees
celsius with fans ramping on about a 100
second delay to the load start that's a
long soak time which is good and speaks
to the size of the heatsink this means
that if you're doing bursty workloads
that are short-lived the fans might not
even spin up the fans ultimately climb
to about 300 rpm to maintain 68 degrees
celsius over 21c ambient not delta t for
this mind you and the rtx 380 fe for
comparison maintained a target of 75 to
76 degrees with its own fan ramp to
around 1830-1900 rpm the 3080 fe cooler
ends up running 2 to 3 dba higher than
the 3090 fe cooler in this scenario
anyway this next chart is for the
automatic fan adjustment and noise
levels versus a 100 workload we run this
workload until the rpm stabilizes and
it's useful for showing us hysteresis
and noise levels during use change in
noise is more noticeable than anything
else with noise so we're looking for as
few swings in the noise as possible in
this line plot starting at a noise floor
of about 26 27 db we can see the cooler
ramps until about 38 dba at 20 inches in
our testing environment this puts it
around where most of the 20 series
partner models were targeting when they
were actually good ones it's not as loud
as past reference coolers from either
amd or nvidia so that seems to be the
main positive and the longer soak time
of just the heatsink when passive is
also a major benefit of the cooler the
density of the fins and the surface area
of the cooler allows it to get away with
this heat load at a lower noise level
than typically we didn't run the 3080fe
as long in our review but we'll plot
this line anyway it reaches maximum fan
ramp much quicker which is a result of
the relative reduction in the ability of
the heatsink to soak change the 3080fe
ramps much faster and more aggressively
and reaches a higher noise level than
the 3090. that's because the 3090s fans
are spinning slower which is benefited
by the larger size of them and the
increased heatsink surface area for this
one we just manually changed the noise
level and normalized for rpm the rtx
3090 fe runs louder than the 3080 fe
which makes sense since the outer edge
of the fan is spinning faster there's
also a little bit more coil line on this
card although that'll vary unit to unit
the end noise level is just under 60 dba
with our measurement approach when at
100 fan speed but in testing the card
never reached 100 fan speed that would
be if you installed multiple in a case
and built a small render farm or similar
or if you're trying to play 8k games and
you need every megahertz possible to get
anywhere close to the playable frame
rates that nvidia led you to expect back
to games at resolutions suitable for
people other than jeff bezos here's red
dead 2. at 4k the rtx 3090 fe manages a
world-changing uplift of 2fps against
the overclocked 3080fe a gain of 2
percent while pulling 8 percent ahead of
the stock 3080 fe in exchange for 114
percent more dollars this wouldn't
matter if it weren't a gaming card
except nvidia has decided that it's a
gaming cart so actually it does matter
at 1440p the rtx 3090 fe is six percent
higher than the rtx 3080 fe stock to
stock not particularly exciting for the
expense don't come anywhere near this
card for 1440p or 1080p gaming and if
you do you should be putting frame rate
limits in place because the fumbling
that will happen on the cpu frame pacing
side will make the overall experience
worse in some games as for 4k it wasn't
really impressive enough there either
this should be marketed only or
primarily as a workstation card at 1080p
the results are identical between the
3080feoc and the 3090 fe and basically
the same stock to stock that's because
we're cpu bound unsurprisingly here's a
look at total war 3 kingdoms at 4k the
rtx 3090 fe stock card ran at 54 fps
average which is 16 higher than the rtx
3080 fe considering most of the cost
really is the memory and the workstation
audience the gaming language attached to
this again doesn't make any sense at
1440p the difference remains 15
that's better than the rumored 10 gains
but against the pricing it's still bad
traditionally with a workstation
targeted card we'd hand wave this and
say that you're buying the card for the
memory and nothing else but that's not
how the marketing worked out finally
gains dropped to 10 percent at 1080p due
to cpu bottlenecking moving on rainbow
six siege at 4k has the 390 fe stock at
203 fps average or 13 ahead of the rtx
3080 fe that may be useful if you're
trying to play rainbow six competitively
and also at 4k for some reason and also
want to approach 240 hertz but still
that's a big price jump for the
performance the 3080 fe already gets
most of the way there compared to 1440p
the 3090 runs at nine percent faster
than the 380 fe at 358 fps average
rather than 329 fps average lows are
about the same in shadow of the tomb
raider the 4k testing positions the rtx
3090 fe at 104 fps average which has
about 13 ahead of the 3080 fe stock card
one percent and 0.1 lows remain roughly
proportionate to the average fps and so
there is consistent scaling here just
not enough to justify the cost again
that's expected and that's also what we
said with the titan rtx you should be
deploying this in workstations don't buy
this card for gaming 8k in scare quotes
or otherwise because you'd be better off
putting that money towards a better cpu
cooling system or almost literally
anything else in the computer
performance at 1440p is 9.8 percent
higher than the 3080fe stock with the
3090 fe stock for whatever that's worth
anyway it's about seven percent faster
than the 3080 oc which is similar to
some stock partner models horizon zero
dawn is our last rasterized only title
because we've already established
performance ranges and we don't need to
keep proving it with other games the
gains here are again amounting to about
13.6 percent versus the 3080 fe stock
although overclocking the fe closes the
range in that's still far from worth it
but since nvidia decided to repeatedly
brand this as a gaming card it's
appropriate to test it as such quake is
a good rtx game to look at developed on
the vulcan api and it's entirely path
traced and as such will benefit the 3000
series more than the 2000 series at 4k
with rtx on the 3090 is running 39 fps
average or 13.6 percent ahead once again
the rt scaling is actually not any
different than the rasterized scaling so
far at 1440p the performance jaunt is
again 13
with the 3090 at 85 fps average and 3080
at 75 fps average the 2080 ti strix for
reference is led by 59 percent against
the 30 90 but even that wasn't as
expensive as the 30 90. at 1080p the gap
shrinks to 12 percent against the 3080
fe from the 30 90 fe which is now
running at 141 fps average if you're
willing to run dlss control benchmarks
at 120 fps average when at 1440p that's
just 7.2 percent ahead of the rtx 3080
fe and the scaling has reduced in this
title so that's it for the review then
of the rtx 3090 video card
we will be doing a lot with these in
overclocking streams for world records
things like that it'll be a lot of fun
it is a top performing card in an
objective sense but that doesn't mean
you should be paying over 100 more for
marketing claims which are totally
irrelevant to the vast majority of
people on planet earth so uh nvidia
unfortunately took a very strong launch
and it fumbled having a lack of
inventory was something that's a bit
more excusable because of the current
situation because of the insane demand
if you look at google search trends just
as an example alone the rtx 30 series
was far more popular than the 20 series
and that was something where especially
after talking to partners
they had real inventory and there were
enough excuses where it was like okay
well so you screwed that up a little bit
maybe i should have waited a little bit
longer but
it's not the complete end of the world
now though they've compounded that which
you can maybe hand wave a little bit
because
nothing's in stock right now ps5 is gone
too phones are regularly gone on launch
day all consoles are gone on launch they
so that was a little easier to hand wave
but now combining with the additional
marketing that was put forth by nvidia's
teams one day before the reviews
properly went up for the 30 90.
we'd have to say this is uh a botched
launch this is nvidia was passed to the
ball
and then it looked around for a teammate
and it saw amd
and it said oh
uh here you go so amd ball is firmly in
your court
don't screw it up
this is this is like your chance to get
some kind of goodwill but the product
still has to be good and obviously we'll
have to test it to see if they're there
for now though
nvidia is still isolated on the charts
at the top end amd has nothing anywhere
nearby and the rtx 3080 actually in an
objective sense is a pretty good
performer it left the 1080 ti behind
finally if you still have one you should
keep using it unless you're truly
unhappy with it because it's still a
really good car even same with the 980
ti's but if you're looking for 8k gaming
you're not going to find it here
that was
we're gonna we're gonna go with uh we're
gonna go with lie for that it was
basically a lie because technically you
can kind of play 8k games
but good luck getting a display and if
you can afford one good luck actually
enjoying things other than the select
titles that nvidia has promoted
unless you're looking to revive say your
counter-strike source or condition zero
career from the early 2000s so then the
cooler actually not bad and we've got
testing for that in this video if you
want to see what acoustics also not bad
nvidia's done a much better job at those
two things this generation the
disassembly of this as you'll see in our
teardown video is pretty similar to the
3080 disassembly so overall nvidia has
improved massively in the mechanical
design and thermal engineering
department versus previous launches
marketing
not so much and performance well it's
not worth spending for just gaming you
should still be buying this basically
only if you're a workstation user don't
get tricked into it from the 8kbs so
workstation users we're going to try and
come back with some additional
specialized tests that we're developing
nvidia only gave us one week between the
launches to work on this cart that's not
enough time to actually do new tests it
was enough time to do the ones that we
had already developed so that's it for
this one thank you for watching
subscribe for more check back for the
live stream with the overclocking of
this card because
it is still objectively good it's just
that the value is objectively bad and
then you can of course go to
patreon.comgamersnexus or
store.gamersnexus.net
to support us directly like by grabbing
one of these shirts we'll see you all
next time
[Music]
the